Hi, guys. How are you? My name is Ilonka
and welcome to another video
on the Netflix channel.
When we were kids, most families
only had an open TV at home.
They had no cable channels,
like cartoons and those things.
And when they broadcasted
children's television,
all the things we saw were anime.
(When we were kids we all saw these anime)
I came to school, when I was 6 years old,
and everyone started talking
about the first episode of POKEMON.
Everybody was watching it. I didn't know
what they were talking about.
So I sat down and I began, diligently,
diligently, diligently,
to watch all POKEMON episodes.
I became a happy girl
who could speak with everybody.
In fact, at recess, we played POKEMON.
And we played to be coaches, and Pokémon,
and we had "Pokémon battles".
All right. Quick attack.
Chu!
Raichu, take down now!
-Rai!
-Pikachu!
-[groans]
-Pika, Pikachu!
Raichu!
Unbelievable!
And I was always Ditto because
Ditto was one of my favorites.
And a boy, one day, I was in 6th grade?
Between 5th and 6th grade.
It was 6th in elementary.
Because in 6th grade,
I became obsessed, just crazy
for an anime called SHAMAN KING.
Let’s go, Amidamaru!
Bason!
Vorpal Dance!
Ainu
I watched it again recently and my heart--
I love it.
Well, on my watch,
when there were no cell phones,
I set it 15 minutes forward
and arrived 15 minutes before
to watch the anime.
I was ready 30 minutes before
in front of the TV, with my dinner served,
to be able to see SHAMAN KING,
which lasted 20 minutes.
About that, in Japan,
Otaku is a person much more obsessed.
At least in Chile, and from
my understanding, in Latin America,
we take the term,
but use it in a lighter way
because we don't have another way to say,
"Hey, I like anime, but calm down."
We have no categories to say
how much you like anime.
So we said, "Oh, Otaku.
You like anime? Oh, Otaku."
There are people who say, "I'm not Otaku."
Well, that's fine. Each person decides.
A tremendous media phenomenon occurred.
Let me tell you, at a national level,
which was called the "Urban Tribes".
They began to form groups,
So all the Tribes had a name.
They had an essence, a look.
And you looked in a certain way.
Curiously,
of the groups that I remember,
there were some like,
Visual K, Oshare, Pecora, Lolita, Otaku,
and the most famous, the Pokemon.
Of which only the Otakus,
they watched anime.
I even remember
that one of the first things I saw,
it was in the newspaper in Antofagasta,
a city that nobody knows.
It was about the Lolitas.
And it was so misinformed
that the Lolitas scared me.
Because I thought they were obsessed women
with some dolls.
And they thought the dolls were alive.
And, indeed, because of that,
my mom was very scared
that I met these groups.
And I would say, "Mom, we watch anime!"
And there, I went
to the Anime Circles because
watching anime was illegal.
And, where could you watch anime?
Thank you, Netflix, for making it legal.
But back then, there was no Netflix.
So my mom literally started going with me
to anime events.
Later on, most of the Urban Tribes
disappeared.
But the Otakus didn't disappear because,
unlike the rest of the Tribes,
ours is my Tribe.
It was a way of life.
We watched anime happily.
This is a bit of a touchy subject.
I'm not going to go into so many details.
But in Latin America,
maybe you already know,
there are usually many social movements,
protests.
And, in Chile,
a very big one happened last year.
But what I do want to tell you is the part
about the people
in the massive protests that took place.
The most significant part were the posters
which were related to anime.
People were walking in the street
in Chile.
Thirty-year-old guys, like me,
they walked with their NARUTO banners,
banners from POKEMON, from YOYO,
from SAILOR MOON.
Actually, there are articles in English
related to the subject.
Like, how Inosuke, KIMETSU NO YAIBA…
(Seeing that you avoid fighting
for your country)
The guy with the pig's head. That one.
It was one of the icons
of Chile's revolution.
There were people who went to the protests
in cosplay.
In Chile, there is a celebrity.
There was a lady who got dressed
with a corporeal Pikachu.
And she was dancing like Pikachu.
And it went viral. Meme.
Because the Pikachu fell
and then the Pikachu got up.
And they all kept dancing.
And she became Aunt Pikachu.
And Aunt Pikachu was one of the icons
of the movement in Chile.
And so, my dear friends, "Netflixistas."
My thesis for "What's it like
being an Otaku in Chile" ends.
It's weird but powerful.
Hit "like" to this video
and comment about what it's like
to be Otaku in your country.
Bye-bye.